as the drought deepens many parts of the
uk face hosepipe bands
the villagers of north end in
oxfordshire find themselves without any
water at all
thames water their supplier had to truck
water into the village after the local
reservoir had to be taken off the main
supply the lack of water from taps it's
been the case that you try and have a
shower you can't and it's just the
frustration of it being day in day out
it keeps going on and off so turning on
the tap is a bit of a surprise if you
get water out of it at the moment we
want a permanent solution that we don't
have to face this whenever divided this
way that is going to be like this every
year in about two weeks time thames
waters 15 million customers will be hit
with hosepipe vans how is this fair i
ask them given it loses a quarter of its
water supply through aging pipes do you
understand
why your customers are angry now they're
being asked to make restrictions yet you
guys are leaking lots of water yes i
mean our customers pay for our water uh
they expect to get water when they need
it for whatever they want to use it for
and i do completely understand that um
so i do think they understand that in
these unprecedented times it makes sense
to ask people to just you know dial down
that non-essential usage put the hose
pipes away and for now there's no
indication the situation for thames
water or its customers will improve if
we go through another dry winter we are
going to see a prolonged period of water
shortage and the drought is going to go
on
water companies will be hoping hosepipe
bans and information campaigns to
conserve water use will prevent the need
for even more severe restrictions on
homes
but outside the drought has already
caused irreparable damage
we haven't had significant rain
until since early june that's where
you're seeing crops dying is that right
absolutely yeah yeah you're not going to
bring that back you can see the battles
lost andrew branton grows potatoes in
south lincolnshire the dry soil just
can't sustain his crop the soil around
it
as you can see is just dust
that is just incredibly dry isn't it
there's not an ounce of moisture in
there would you expect these to be
larger at this time of year
they should be
four times that size currently he's
irrigating his fields but with continued
heat and no rain on the horizon it's
likely the environment agency will
suspend farmers licenses to do this in
order to protect fragile rivers and
domestic supplies it's a distinct risk
and yeah once that's taken away from us
game over it's something society has to
decide which is more important is it
domestic water
is it water for agriculture to produce
food or is it the environment because
there isn't enough to go around
making agriculture homes and the
environment more resilient to drought
requires investment fewer leaks more
reservoirs better irrigation
a hard sell in the midst of a cost of
living crisis tom clark sky news